our findings and in resolving the
circumstances facing Americans and
people from around the world and the
crew on the ground princess first the
results among those tested 46 persons
were swab 21 of those on the ship tested
positive for the corona virus 24 tested
negative one test was inconclusive again
let me say 21 21 individuals on the
grand princess tested positive among
those with 19 crew members and two
passengers and it's important it's
important to note yes among those
positive for a corona virus were 19 crew
members and two passengers it's
important to note that the Grand
Princess actually was on its second tour
and we know of corona virus infections
from the first tour as well with very
very difficult results in the wake of
these findings today we've been working
through the day with the governor Newsom
and his administration through their
unified command efforts in California
CDC and HHS and we have developed a plan
which will be implemented this weekend
to bring the ship into a non commercial
port all passengers and crew will be
tested for the corona virus those that
need to be quarantined will be
quarantined those that require
additional medical attention will
receive it let me assure the American
public as we did so with Americans
returning from China and those returning
from the other cruise ship we are taking
all measures necessary to see to the
health of the Americans and those
involved on the grand princess and just
as importantly to protect the health of
the American public and prevent the
spread of the disease through
communities in this country it is a we
are instituting the strongest testing
protocols to ensure that not only those
on board receive the treatment that they
need
but that American people can be
confident that there will be no erosion
in our preventative measures in efforts
to keep the corona virus from spreading
throughout our country I want to express
our gratitude to governor Newsom in the
state of California for their full
partnership not just in dealing with the
Grand Princess but throughout the advent
of the corona virus California has been
a strong partner and as I just told the
governor a few moments ago we will
continue to work very closely with his
administration and we will continue to
put the health and safety of America
first with that let me turn my attention
to the the issue of testing which has
been much in the news of late and the
president spoke about it just a few
moments ago at the CDC it's very
important to note that because of
president Trump's decisive leadership
that the risk to the American public of
contracting to coronavirus does remain
low but nevertheless in Washington state
where I visited yesterday with members
of our team and in California we have
seen as dr. Fauci often describes a
community transmission still less than
200 cases across the country and the
good news is most Americans who have
contracted this disease are being
treated and recovering and on the road
to recovery sadly we all know of the
loss of life and we grieve that along
with their families but the American
people deserve to know that we are ready
and that because of the president's
leadership and because of extraordinary
efforts by CDC and Health and Human
Services and our partners in state labs
around the country we have the testing
necessary to be able to provide tests to
all the states that have requested as I
said yesterday we've been able to
provide tests to all the state
jurisdictions and labs that have
requested it and I'm pleased to report
that all state labs have the test and
now because of the change the president
Trump implemented at the FDA a week ago
now state labs can actually conduct
coronavirus tests themselves beyond that
between March 2nd and 5th we distributed
more than 900,000 tests across the
country including 200,000 that could
allow 75 individual patients 75,000
individual patients to be tested as the
Secretary of HHS just described by
tomorrow another 200,000 tests will be
shipped and by the weekend another
million tests will be shipped around the
country with the expectation that at the
end of next week 4 million tests will be
shipped we've been able to respond to
the requests of states that have been
impacted by the corona virus but as I
said yesterday to meet future demand
this week the president brought together
the leading commercial labs in America
and asked them to in effect partner with
the United States in developing tests
for the American people and I'm proud to
say that just in the last 24 hours
LabCorp requests two of America's
leading commercial laboratories have
announced that tests will be available
by Monday of this week the reason that's
important the reason that meets future
demand is because the enormous capacity
of these commercial laboratories and
others in the country are precisely how
we will make coronavirus tests available
for your local doctor available to your
pharmacy and broadly available to the
American public tomorrow dr. Steve Hahn
at the FDA
we'll come to this room and and briefed
in specific our efforts with regard to
testing to assure the American public
that every effort is being made to
provide testing resources not just for
state laboratories not just for
universities not just for hospitals in
affected areas but with the announcement
of these major commercial labs we trust
in a matter of weeks the coronavirus
test will be broadly available to the
public and available in any American
that is symptomatic and has a concern
about about the possibility of having
contracted the corona virus we've made
great progress but there is much work to
be done over the course of this weekend
I'll be traveling to Florida but to meet
with Cruise Line executives we'll be
discussing with them in particular what
additional measures our Cruise Lines
could take to ensure the health and
safety of the American public and I look
forward to those conversations tomorrow
I want to introduce dr. Fauci for a
comment and then I'll also introduce the
year the Admiral and Bob cloudy Feldick
about about our plans with regard to the
cruise ship but let me make a maybe make
one last comment if I may before we hear
from other members of the task force
I've said it twice let me say it again
the general risk to the American public
remains low but if you are an individual
with a serious underlying health
condition or and are elderly it's
important to take precautions and use
common sense particularly as it relates
to travel we want to recognize from the
experience now of two cruise ships the
cruise ships represent a unique
challenge for health officials and and
so we would ask elderly Americans to use
common sense and caution in planning any
cruise ship vacation
in the future but they can be assured
we're gonna be working closely with some
great American companies in the cruise
line industry to enhance and strengthen
the screening procedures that take place
as as passengers board and as they
disembark with that let me let me yield
for a few moments to dr. pouchy and then
we'll hear from other members of the
task force about the Grand Princess as
well as testing dr. Falchi thank you
very much mr. vice president I just want
to take the opportunity very briefly
last time I was here at the podium we
were talking about what the vice
president said about the risk of getting
infected and how we need to distinguish
that from if you are infected like the
unfortunate situation that we've seen in
Seattle and what we're seeing on cruise
ships is that in that group of people
who get infected the ones who are
clearly the most vulnerable to getting
the complications of serious disease and
even death of people with underlying
conditions particularly among the
elderly with underlying conditions and
there was a heart disease lung disease
kidney disease diabetes etc so what I'd
like to do today is is sort of like
publicly answer a question that I get
asked all the time now is that if you
are a person with an underlying
condition the conditions that I just
mentioned particularly if you're an
elderly person with that as the vice
president said beyond even cruise ships
to just use the common sense of trying
to protect yourself because you're the
most vulnerable that is often referred
to as social distancing and what we mean
by that is if you're a person who is in
that category think twice even before
you get on a plane for a long trip or
you want to travel you want to go to a
place that's crowded where there may be
people who are in fact have an infection
of any sort that doesn't necessarily
have to be even coronavirus it could be
influenza or anything
like that so I want to publicly answer
the question that I keep getting asked
in a private situation if you're in that
category or if you're the family of
individuals in that category take care
to try and take care of the most
vulnerable among them and there are
simple things that you can do practical
common-sense about not putting yourself
in a situation whatever that might be
that might increase the risk given your
situation thank you with that I'd like
to introduce Vice Admiral Abel who again
the Coast Guard did heroic work
transporting tests to the Grand Princess
and is going to play a key role as we
implement as we implement the process of
resolving the first of all we'd like to
send our appreciation out to the members
of the 129th
air risky recovery wing the California
Air National Guard that played a key
role last night in getting the the test
kits out to the ship retrieving those
test kits it's great to have shipmates
like that that stand by our side when
the nation needs it Coast Guard looks
forward to operationalizing the best
risk mitigation plan that's developed on
medical science from the state local and
federal level and we use our captain at
the port authorities it's a director
ship to execute that plan thank you and
Bob Kadlec is the assistant secretary
who's been coordinating the preparedness
and the response to the Grand Prince
thank you very much mr. vice president
and good evening everyone I just wanted
to say first of all thanks to governor
Newsom and his staff at the State Health
Office and emergency management in
California they've been in extraordinary
great partners not only during this
event as we're developing a concept of
opera plant operations and planning - if
you will disembark passengers from that
ship safely and effectively ensuring
that their safety as well as the
community that they will be coming into
will be protected I just want to say
that they've been great partners
throughout this they've been critical in
a repeater
and efforts from Wuhan as well as from
the diamond princess ship in Japan and
again the details are becoming more
apparent and will brief you as those
become more firm but I just want to say
it's a whole government of effort we're
working with Department of Defense with
the Coast Guard Department of Homeland
Security our colleagues at CDC as well
as the state and local authorities in
California to ensure that we can bring
those people home safely as well as and
as quickly as possible
thank you thank you thank you mr. vice
president's so this will be a
comprehensive plan that like our other
group on Diamond Princess was a
comprehensive approach to ensure the
health and welfare of all of our
citizens as dr. Falchi discussed we know
many of the people on the cruise ship
are in their 60s 70s and 80s and we want
to make sure as we know that that's a
more vulnerable group that we pay
special attention to anybody who has any
comorbidities or other conditions and so
we're working very hard with the people
on the ship and the medical team there
to make sure that their health and
welfare is prioritized thank you and dr.
Steven Hahn with the FDA just as a
reminder about this test this is a swab
test not a point-of-care test if you
discuss that yesterday but that's the
component of this test it is a test
that's been developed by the CDC based
upon their first obtaining the seat the
genetic sequence of the virus that test
is very high-quality we have high
confidence in that test that test is now
available in all public health labs
that's described by the Vice President
in response to the demand that we're
seeing for the test we are increasing
the supply of this test as described by
the Vice President and we believe that
that will be available significantly
across the country and
provide more details tomorrow just for
specific numbers if you will as of
yesterday the CDC test was shipped out
900,000 tests we have another 200,000
which we expect to be shipped out
tomorrow and have gone through the
Quality Assurance process another 1
million tests will be quality assessed
this weekend and we expect those to go
out early next week we expect further
surge in test capacity beyond that by
the end of next week and again I'm
really happy to provide you tips so I
think that's a question that should
probably be addressed to the CDC for the
most accurate number thank you
well we're going to get to the bottom of
it but it's very likely that the crew on
the grand princess was exposed on on two
different two different outings and and
we know the corona virus manifested
among the previous passengers and so
we'll find that out but we will be
testing everyone on the ship we will be
quarantine e as necessary but with
regard to the 1100 member crew we
anticipate that they will be quarantined
on the ship will not need to disembark
but let me let me refer to a secretary
Catholic and to respond we're working
literally hour by hour with the
Department of Defense and with the state
of California to identify the military
bases where we'll do the testing of the
remaining passengers yes sir thank you
and it is true
truly evolving right now obviously
they've been bases that been identified
before Travis Lockland and we're working
with the Department of Defense to
identify the appropriate settings again
realizing that we're trying to ensure
both the safety of the passengers and
the safety
communities that are around them so
happy to answer any more questions Thank
You president
ain't packing just the last little while
send out a notification to people who
attended the conference to say to people
from New York who attended the
conference have tested positive for
coronavirus are you concerned that the
virus is now here in Washington DC and
there's a lot of members of Congress
attend AIPAC
are you concerned that some members of
Congress may have contracted the virus
well let me say that's the first I've
heard of it in the midst of a busy day
and we will be engaged I'm confident in
the same contract contact tracing that
we are for any case but maybe maybe dr.
Fauci could speak to a concern about the
nation's capital deterioration yeah you
know again when you have lack of
information it's tough to make anything
definitive but obviously if you have
someone who is here I mean the risk of
there being a major outbreak obviously
is which everybody thinks about but what
will happen is that those individuals
that were infected will have contact
tracing and that's the public health
weapon if you want to call it that we
have the name need to get those people
isolated and to do the contact tracing
we don't have enough information out
because this is the first that I've
actually heard about it also with a busy
day so as soon as we get further
information we'd be happy to share that
with you said that anybody that needs a
test can have a test they're all set can
we drill down on that when exactly well
a person who feels like they may have
coronavirus can they go into their
doctor's office and get a test in
addition to that mr. vice president just
a short while ago the president
described governor Inslee of Washington
State who you just met with yesterday as
a snake he also described the
coronavirus test
compared it to the phone call that he
had with the leader of Ukraine is the
president addressing the situation with
the seriousness it requires well I
promise you president Trump has no
higher priority than the health and
safety of the American people and he's
assembled an extraordinary group of
Americans and agencies I'm a little more
than a week into leading the White House
coronavirus effort and I couldn't be
more proud and more impressed the team
that the president assembled but I think
your first question is a very important
one Jim and I appreciate it
the president's exactly right that for
the state laboratories for the
communities that have been impacted that
have concerns about the coronavirus we
have been able to respond to requests
for tests and literally you can hear
that the test that's been made available
since the first of this month is
literally mounts and the hundreds of
thousands of millions of tests but for
the American public to have access to
the coronavirus test it's the reason why
President Trump brought in this week all
of the CEOs of the top commercial
laboratories in the country they're the
ones that we believed could spin up a
new test very rapidly they have enormous
logistics and manufacturing capabilities
and we said to them we want you to work
together because while whilst all state
labs can now conduct their own tests and
while we as I described and as dr. Han
described we've distributed hundreds of
thousands in fact over a million tests
around the country to get it all across
the American people to your local doctor
to your pharmacy to what when my kids
were a little we used to call the med
check it's going to require these
commercial labs and the good news is it
didn't get too widely reported but both
LabCorp and quest two of the largest
commercial labs in the country just
announced that by Monday they will have
tests available for distribution and
sales
across the country if I get a spotless
vice president if somebody is feeling
he'll this weekend and they go to the
doctor on Monday can the doctor request
a coronavirus test any American in the
country or we not at that point I just
want to make sure that it's crystal
clear in terms of what the expectations
are well I think for any American that
is symptomatic speaking to your doctor
if you have reason to believe that you
have been exposed to the corona virus I
have every confidence your physician
would contact state health officials and
have access to the state lab we made
those tests available to the state labs
I've spoke to governor of Roy Cooper of
North Carolina today I spoke to Governor
Bryant Camp Georgia last night and we've
been working hard to make sure that
we're where we have suspected cases that
we've been making tests available but
you make a very fair point about the
wider availability to doctors and
physicians and clinics will happen we
believe because of the of the
collaboration that president Trump
forged with our commercial labs and the
great news is is they announced
yesterday by Monday the two of the
largest commercial labs in America
announced they will have tests and begin
to take them to market Thank You mr.
vice president two questions if I could
one on workers and one on families the
first one on workers there are a lot of
Americans who are worried about losing
wages if they're forced to stay home
because they're not on a regular salary
is the White House preparing any sort of
economic mitigation effort for workers
who suffer wage losses here and the
second one is on families which is
you're telling people to stay home if
they feel sick like what's your advice
to parents of children who might have a
lot of vulnerable people in their
households should they be quarantine
themselves with their children in the
house or they need to be quarantined
themselves some somewhere else away from
their own families
well with regard to your first question
I will tell you that I've been very
inspired at the response of businesses
around this country and their
sensitivity and decision-making about
Americans who are potentially impacted
by the corona virus but but I will tell
you in the days ahead when I was on
Capitol Hill this week meeting with
Republicans and Democrats in the house
in the Senate week we talked about
should this become much more much more
widespread in the country there were
recommendations from Congress which I
know we would we would carefully
consider but let me your second question
I think might be the most important one
asked and that is for for families what
are the best practices at home and I'd
like to ask dr. Burks to address that
that's an excellent question I come from
a multi-generational household I have
nine month-old two-year-old
grandchildren my parents live in the
same household they're 91 and 96 and my
daughter and husband are there and I
think this is a very critical question
and it's why over the last week we've
really been focused on who is the most
vulnerable who needs to be protected and
ensuring that every family understands
that and I think your question is
critical because it comes back to what
doctor found she said if they follow
good hand washing techniques if they
ensure that everything is washed that is
used with the grandparents if they
ensure that the children if ill are kept
away from the grandparents and somewhat
separated in the household with strong
cleaning and other hand washing and hand
touching pieces this is what social
distancing can occur in the household
and that's really the focus that we have
that every household has the capacity in
order to ensure this health and welfare
of their elderly and others with medical
conditions and I don't want to I want to
make sure we've also emphasized that
because anyone that has an
immunodeficiency independent of age is
someone else that we have to be very
careful with and ensuring that we're
protecting them those family members who
are not infected to stay somewhere else
so if you've got a couple of kids one
who's infected and the other ones are
not should you send the ones who are
still healthy somewhere else or do you
need to quarantine everybody I'm looking
at dr. Falchi and I think that's a great
question and we're gonna talk about that
and I don't think there really is a
decisive answer about that it depends
upon the feasibility of do you have
someplace to put the child I think that
if you're in a situation where you
really cannot do it then you just sort
of say well I'm gonna keep them both
together realizing that with children
and this gets back to what I just said a
little while ago the the risk of there
being a problem of infection where the
children is really very low if you look
at all of the reports from every place
from China from Italy from from Korea
it's it's the same when do you when is
that target date when do we expect any
American who wants a test to seem they'd
be able to get it
let me ask dr. Han to respond to that
but when we met with the major
commercial labs in addition to I want to
emphasize that again because of the
because of the changes that the FDA may
now all state labs can perform a
coronavirus test and I spoke to one
governor about that today and we
clarified that with them we've
distributed these kits with hundreds of
thousands and over a million tests more
to come but but to to get the tests
widely distributed across the country I
couldn't be more grateful that our
commercial labs have have already
announced two of the leading commercial
labs in America that they'll create a
product but let me talk to
let me let you talk to dr. Han because
the FDA is in the process of working
with those companies and and see if dr.
Ahn has a sense but I remember that they
told us given their enormous production
capability that in a matter of weeks not
months that we could be seeing
coronavirus broadly distributed around
the country and then growing literally
by the day dr. Han about right that's
correct
do you have some idea of how many test
kids we are going to meet so I'm going
to use the term tests not kits so that
we can be clear about you know sort of
the lexicon that we're using so as I
mentioned as of tomorrow we expect 1.1
million tests to have been shipped to
laboratories and those would have gone
to mostly non public health laboratories
in answer to your question because I'm
thinking like a doctor here if I were
with the patient who came in I wanted to
test what I would recommend to that
provider is to contact as the vice
president said their local public health
group because they're gonna be able to
know about availability in that state
but as the vice president says with
these converge commercial labs having
the ability to now scale up those tests
this is a critical part of this in
addition to the millions of testing
tests tests that will be sending out
this upcoming week as well as what we've
already done we expect that to surge
substantially so we'll talk a little
about this tomorrow it's a complicated
answer to the question I don't want to
mislead the American public but one test
doesn't necessarily equal one patient
and so that equation I think is worth
discussing in more detail
number one presidents directed a
whole-of-government approach we're
leaning into this effort and we're gonna
work with our commercial partners we're
gonna work with the CDC and we're gonna
meet that need for the American public
and I'm confident of that
particularly as I see the way frankly
see the way state government's state
health department's public laboratories
and our commercial laboratories have
stepped up let me also say as I said
yesterday when we were in Washington
State one of the things the CDC has done
is in the midst of these numbers that
could get a little blurry at the time
we'll make sure you have all of them in
detail and dr. Han will detail it
tomorrow we have prioritized areas of
the country where we have community
transmission and the recommendation of
our experts is we've been focusing tests
in California and in Washington State
I've had those conversations with both
of those governors and we'll continue to
do that even as we work to build a wider
availability you have encouraged caution
and social distancing for elderly
Americans and people who have
pre-existing conditions does anything at
the government statistics people who are
over 65 that's 50 million Americans
people who have pre-existing condition
conditions us another 50 million to a
hundred million Americans are you
essentially saying that a third of the
country maybe up to half of the country
should have caution before traveling and
if that's the case should major events
major conferences political rallies just
be canceled at this point because they
would include a large percentage of
elderly Americans and people with treats
it well let me try it again
a lot of facts and a lot of informations
let me be as clear as I can what I want
to say today is in consultation with
these experts is that as we look at the
data initial data in this country and
data coming in from around the world and
that elderly with serious underlying
health and conditions are the most
vulnerable to the coronavirus let me say
that again that elderly individuals with
underlying health conditions are the
most vulnerable to serious results from
the coronavirus and so today we say with
great respect that it is a good time for
any American who is elderly by however
they define it and has a serious
underlying health condition to think
carefully about travel and make dr.
Fauci was clear on that and I'd like him
to have the last word so numbers in and
the statistics you said correct but
there's really a difference between an
underlying condition and a serious
underlying condition that would actually
compromise you so let me explain by the
numbers that you said someone who has
high blood pressure is on a blood
pressure medication and has got it down
pretty well as an underlying condition
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
that might be quite intimate and oxygen
is a serious underlying condition
there's a big difference between
somebody with controlled hypertension
and somebody with congestive heart
failure and chronic pulmonary disease so
although your numbers are correct
it isn't really one third of the
American population
do you have a number at CDC
[Music]
[Music]